اصبرت نتائج اوليه تقدم الجمهوريين على
الديمقراطيين في انتخابات التجديد النصفيه
الخاصه
بمقاعدي مجلس النواب بينما تحترم المنافسه
بين المعسكريين في انتخابات مجلس الشيوخ
وتجري الانتخابات على 35 مقعدا في مجلس
الشيوخ وجميع مقاعد لمجلس هي النواب
البالغي عددها
435 وبين ما يتواصلوا عدد الاصوات سافادت
محطات امريكيه بان الجمهوريين حصلوا حتى
الان على مئه وسبعه وتسعين مقعدا في
النواب مقابل
167 للديموقراطيين فيما يتعلقوا بمجلس
الشيوخ فقد حصلت ديمقراطيونا على 48 مقادا
مقابله سبعه واربعين للجمهوريه ويسعى الى
الحزبين لتامين 2008 مقعدا في مجلس النواب
لضمان الاغلبيه بينما يسعيان للحصول على
واحده وخمسين وقعدا لضمان اغلبيه مجلس
الشيوخ المكون من مئه مقال
سريعه كانت ردود الفعل على نتائج
الانتخابات النصفيه الامريكيه اذ قال
سيناتور الجمهوريه الينسيجرام انه من
الواضح انه لا يتم مشاهده موجه حمراء اي
اكتساح للجمهوريين في الانتخابات كما كان
متوقعا
ذهبوا الى واشنطن ينضم الينا من هناك محمد
العلمي محمد اخر النتائج لو تحدثنا عنها
وربما النتائج كما اشرتم قبل قليل هناك
تقدم
للجمهوريين في مجلس النواب وتقدم طفيف
بصوت واحد
للديمقراطيين في مجلس الشيوخ لكن هناك
مقاعد كثيره في مجلس النواب لم يعرف
مصيرها حتى هذه اللحظه في حين هناك
اربعه مقاعد في مجلس الشيوخ ما زال الصراع
بشانها محتدما همم في وسكانسن اريزونا
نيفادا وجورجيا واا بالنسبه لجورجيا همم
ربما سي- يتعين او بالتاكيد الان سيتعين
انتظار جوله الاعاده في السادس من هذا
الشهر لكن الخلاصه المؤكده او ابرز عنوان
لهذه الليله او هذا الصباح الان هو انه
الى ذلك السيناتور الجمهوري للزيران انه
لم تكن هناك اي موجه حمراء كما كان متوقعا
على نطاق واسع همم ربما يعزى ذلك للدعايه
الانتخابيه الشديده من الحزب الجمهوري او
كبوه اخرى لاستطاعته الراي العام او حتى
عدم الثقه همم من الديمقراطيين او من
بعضهم على الاقل الذين همم استسلموا
لهزيمه همم متوقعه وبداوا يتحدثون فقط عن
اختصار او تقليل وقعتين بتاع الهزيمه خاصه
في مجلس النواب مع هذه النتائج ازدادت
امال الديمقراطيين على الاقل للاحتفاظ
بمجلس الشيوخ همم وقد ينتظرون همم
سباق جورجيا او جوله الاعاله في السادس من
هذا الشهر ان لم يستطيع ضمان مقعدين اخرين
همم اه في اريزونا او نيفادا كما هو متوقع
الى حد ما
لكنهم قد ينتظرون جورجيا كما انتظروها همم
قبل عامين
ونجحت تلك الولايه التي كانت حمراء حتى
عهد قريب في منحي الديمقراطيين مقعدين في
مجلس الشيوخ الذي رفع عدد مقاعد بهم الى
50 مقابله 50 لدى الحزب ارجو الجمهوري لكن
ما رجعها كافه همم الديمقراطيين في مجلس
الشيوخ هو انا نائمه الرئيس الدستوريه هي
رئيسه مجلس الشيوخ وبالتالي تصوت مع
الديمقراطيين حينما تتساوى الاصوات حول اي
مشروع قانون يعرض على المجلس اذا حتى الان
النتائج ايجابيه الى حد ما بالنسبه
للديمقراطيين او على الاقل افضل من
توقعاتهم همم
بمستوى الكبير الجمهوريون حتى هذه اللحظه
واضح انهم في طريقهم الى السيطره على مجلس
النواب لكن ليست بتلك الاغلبيه التي كانوا
يمنون النفس بها وكان ذلك واضحا في حملتهم
الانتخابيه التي انتقلت الى المعاقل
الكلاسيكيه الديمقراطيين في خاصه في ولايه
نيويورك وكاليفورنيا وحسافه في بعض
الولايات الشمال الغربي للولايات المتحده
كاوريجن وولايه واشنطن في اقصى الشمال
الغربي للولايات المتحده لكن على الرغم من
ذلك التوسع الاستراتيجي للانتخابي وانفاق
اموال غير مسبوقه وهذا من الحزبين طبعا
همم لكن همم لم تتحقق همم
اول ما يتحقق الحديث او الامال عن همم
موجه حمراء او سمعه البعض تسونامي احمر
همم ياكل الاخضر واليابس ويعطي الحزب
الجمهوري اغلبيه مريحه جدا في مجلس
واغلبيه همم ربما اقل راحه لكنها اغلبيه
في نهايه مطافي مجلس الشيوخ بسبب همم نقمه
واحبال الراي العام الامريكي من حاله همم
الاقتصاد ومن ارتفاع الاسعار والتضخم الى
غريل ذلك لكن تضح ان شريحه كبيره من
الناخبين الامريكيين ومن الديمقراطيين او
من المستقلين ايضا كانت لهم اهتمامات اخرى
وبرزت همم في هذه الانتخابات قضيه الاجهاض
همم المحكمه العليا كما يعرف الكثير من
المشاهدين كانت قد
صوتت همم لالغاء همم قالون او قرار سابق
لها همم يسمح همم
بالاجهاض في بعض الحالات الخاصه لكن
المحكمه اليمنيه الان او التي يغلب عليها
اليمين الغد ذلك القرار مما همم اثار
حفيظه الكثير من الديمقراطيين
عاقلين وحتى بعض الجمهوريين الذين يؤمنون
بحريه المراه في بعض الحالات وان الحكومه
لا دخل لها في هذا القرار ويبدو ان هذه
النقطه بالتحديد كانت وراء ذهاب الكثير من
النساء الغاضبات على هذا القرار من اجل
الترجيح كافه الحزب الديمقراطي على الاقل
التقليل من الخساره الفادحه التي كانت
متوقعه واسعه